je vous envoie mes compliments pour
stress temp depuis tout ça j'irai mes
bons salots que je ne reviendrai pas je
n'ai plus rien à voir je n'ai plus rien
à
[Musique]
croire là où je suis à les montagnes le
frère il est Ballé et je pêche à la
ligne avec un ami anglais je comprends
pas ce qu'il dit et on s'entend très
bien qu'il est grand ce pays que la
terre est
loin je n'ai plus de nouvelles de vos
journaux à la con S de vos poubelles le
temps semble moins long j'ai coupé mes
dépenses et cette fois pour de
bon j'ai rencontré une petite sœur qui
vaut vraiment le coup elle s'est mis une
balle en plein cœur S qu'elle était à
bout et elle et moi on fait les choses
et elle me sourit
beaucoup qu'il est grand P
que la terre est
loin ici a rien à faire que le vent dans
tes cheveux et la vie tout entière
repasse sous nos yeux comme c'était un
mystère qu'on n'y a vu que du
feu je n'ai plus de nouvell ce qui sont
au pays et mes amis me manquent tu TS
que j'ai tes envies je les revois encore
je ne su plus envie et
alors qu'il est grand ce pays que la
terre est
[Musique]
loin s'il y a de
l'espérance alors toi seul le
sais
qu'il est grand ce pays tu vois on se
[Musique]
rejoint des
montagnes des prairies et je pêche à la
ligne avec mon trèsbon ami même si on
comprend rien ce qu'on fait
ici